تشهدوا سد وادي فاطمه في منطقه مكه
المكرمه غربيا السعوديه هذه الايام توافد
اعداد كبيره من الزوار الباحثين عن
الطبيعه وجمالها في ظل استمرار الحاله
المطريه التي تشهدها المنطقه
باللون الاخضر يعد هذا السد سد وادي فاطمه
من اشهر السدود السعوديه عام
1985 لتغذيه المصادر الجوفيه لمياه الابار
وتامين مياه الشرب في مدينه مكه وجده
من وادي فاطمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلامي سلطان مرحبا بك
المنظر ولا اروع يا سلطان بس خلينا ناخذ
معكم جوله نشوف فيها يعني هذا المنطقه
وادي فاطمه من اكثر من زاويه
مشاهدي قناه العربيه بالفعل الجو جو مكشات
وطبخ واستئناف يعني خلال الفتره الماضيه
اليومين والسميع الماضيه شهدت وادي فاطمه
وتحديدا سد وادي فاطمه الكثير المتنزهين
من اهالي منطقه مكه المكرمه وحتى الزوار
القادمين من خارج منطقه مكه المكرمه هذه
المنطقه يعني طبعا
للمياه والامطار بشكل كبير جدا مما جعلها
يعني بساط اخطر اللون مع شريان للمياه في
كثير من الاوديه والمناطق المجاوره لهذا
السد الذي يغذي العديد من المزارع ولا
اوديه والمناطق الزراعيه هنا في منطقه
الجنوب التي تشتهر بكثره المزارع والاوديه
وبزاعه التمور والليمون وغيرها من
الورقيات في هذه المنطقه يعني خلال اسابيع
الماضيه كان ممتلئ هذا الوادي بشكل كبير
جدا بالزواره متنزه له لازال ويتواجدون
وتوافيدون بشكل يومي وبشكل الاستمتاع
بالاجواء الساحره ولا صوت يعلو على صوت
ربيع كما تشاهد الجبال والاوديه مكتسبه
بالخضار الكامل رغما الامطار يعني انتهت
خلال الثلاث اربعه ايام الماضي لكن لا
يزال اللون الاخضر يطغى على هذه المناطق
ربيعيه جميله مناسبه للاستمتاع وزيارتها
وقضاء الاوقات السعيد هنا طبعا نتحدث على
مناطق اخرى كبيره جدا استفاده من هذا السد
الذي يستطيع احتواء 20 مليون متر مكعب من
المياه من ما جاء على هذه المنطقه خضراء
وتجري فيها المياه واستردت الكثير من
المناطق الزراعيه
والحيويه هنا من اهالي المنطقه الاثير منه
هذا الوادي وادي فاطمه تحدث انه ياتي من
همم قمم من جبال الطائف فصول الى محافظه
جده ويصب مياه هذا الوادي في البحر الاحمر
وادي كبير يبلغ طول وقرابه 210 كيلو متر
ولدين نستضيف معي الاستاذ عبد الهادي
العتيبي وهو احد اهالي هذه المنطقه للحديث
عن كيف كانت هذه الاجواء وهذه المنطقه
خلال ايام الماضيه وشهاده اهلا وسهلا بك
على شاشه العربيه اجواء جميله خضره نشاهد
جريان المياه قرب السد كيف كانت هذه
المنطقه خلال الايام الماضيه السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته المنطقه هذه كانت قبل
السد شبه قاحله يعني سبحان الله فاراد
الله صارت بالجمال هذا الخبر الطبيعي
والجمال الطبيعي هذا طيب انا بسالك ابو
عبد الهادي ابو مجاهد عن المنطقه ايش
المياه اللي تغديها المزارع او المزارع
اتغديها مياه سد وادي فاطمه
بصفه عامه للجمهور جميله جدا وتغذي الريان
والطرفان والمناطق اللي مرتفعه فوق السد
وهذه المنطقه كلها سبعه سبحان الله
السد بهذا الشكل واللون الاخضر الذي يكتسي
الارض بشكل كامل وادي فاطمه كثير من
الاوديه والمناطق في العاصمه المقدسه كيف
شفت المنظر ده بعد انقطاع سنوات
هذه يمكن لها اكثر من 10 سنوات بس انا هذه
سبحان الله ما قدر الله وراءك لكن الواجب
عامه جميل يعني
وشفتوا زوار من خارج المنطقه موجودين هنا
من جميع انحاء المنطقه الغربيه من جده من
مكه من ضواحي الجموم والوادي هذا كله كل
يوم في زياده زوار
جيران المياه في سد وادي فاطمه
لكن الامور كلها سهله كلها يعني
خالد انا اعطيك يعني دعوه رسميه من قبل
ومن قبل اهالي وادي منطقه وادي فاطمه
بزياره هذه المنطقه
والاستمتاع بشكل كبير جدا بالمناظر
الطبيعيه على هذا الجبل الذي امامنا يعني
نساء كامل بالاخضر كان انا في احد المناطق
الاوروبيه بدون مبالغه يا خالد
يعطيك صوره لهذا الجبل المكتسب باللون
الاخضر بشكل كبير يعني سنوات طويله لم
نشاهد هذه المناظر في منطقه مكه المكرمه
تحديدا ولكن مع كثره هطول الامطار خلال
الفتره الماضيه مما جاء على الاوديه
والمراكز والمحافظات التابعه لمنطقه مكه
المكرمه مكتسبه بالخضار وجيران وجيران
المياه في العديد من الاوديه من مجال
الاستفاده كبيره للمزارع والاهالي وكذلك
حتى السكان متنزهين لقيوا فرصه كبيره
للاستمتاع بهذه الاجواء وهذه كذلك تتكلم
عن درجه الحراره اليوم هي لا تتجاوز ال 25
درجه مئويه وهي درجه مناسبه لاستمتاع
نتواجد حاليا في احد المناطق فقط لكن
بالقرب مني هنالك مناطق كبيره جدا وعديده
ومختلفه المواقع قرابه جده وقرابه مكه
والطائف هي مليئه بالخضار والاجواء
الطبيعيه نعم